the path to the chernobyl power plant is
barren overgrown and lonesome this
amusement park nearby was due to open
five days after the 1986 nuclear
meltdown whose name is now synonymous
with disaster
it never did
36 years later radiation levels are
still well above normal in some places
that's high
visoka
the reading is about 16 times normal
inside explosion ravaged reactor number
four now shrouded by a large container
radiation levels remain high
vladimir vurbitsky still a chernobyl
engineer rushed to the plant the day of
the meltdown
when i got there i was expecting to see
the reactor
what i saw was the crater left by the
explosion
with the zapariza nuclear plant taking
fire repeatedly in front line fighting
in southern ukraine locals say it could
pose an even greater danger
i worked at chernobyl and i witnessed
the tragic consequences of the explosion
zapariza could be two three four times
bigger than chernobyl and i'm very
worried about that
believe it or not this is the center of
the town of prippet that's the cultural
building behind me on the day after the
meltdown at chernobyl all 50 000
residents were evacuated and not a soul
has lived here since
now nature has reclaimed the landscape
on which prepit was built
the president of the company that owns
the zaparisia plant says russian forces
have placed trucks and explosives inside
turbine holds near the reactor and are
firing from the plant's grounds russia
blames ukraine for the strikes on the
plant it is an act of nuclear terrorism
and they continue in this way
unlike chernobyl vladimir furbitsky says
zaparisia is europe's biggest nuclear
plant and it lies in a heavily populated
region
this won't happen in russia the west
will feel the consequences bulgaria
romania moldova and poland
he hopes both russia and ukraine have
learned the lessons of chernobyl so the
land that surrounds zapposia doesn't
also become a nuclear wasteland for
decades to come john hendren al jazeera
the chernobyl exclusion zone ukraine